Categorize each of the following
statements as true or false.
If an event is
unlikely to occur,
its probability
will be negative.
No.
Your probability can
never be negative.
Even if something is impossible,
then the probability will be 0.
If it's highly unlikely,
it'll be close to 0,
but it'll be still positive.
Probabilities are
always between 0 and 1.
0 means it is impossible.
It cannot happen.
1 means that it's a certainty
that it will happen.
And the values in between
say how likely or unlikely
they are.
Probabilities
greater than 0.5 say,
hey, it's more likely than not.
Probabilities less than 0.5,
it's more unlikely than not.
And probabilities
of 0.5 say, hey,
it's just as likely to
happen or as to not happen.
An event with
probability 3/5 is less
likely to occur than an
event with probability 3/4.
So 3/5 is a smaller
number than 3/4.
We have the same numerator.
We have a larger denominator.
3 is a smaller fraction
of 5 than it is of 4.
So since 3/5 is a
smaller number than 3/4--
and it's more obvious if you
see it as a decimal-- 3/5
is 0.6 while 3/4 is 0.75.
So this is less likely to occur.
This is true.
The probability of getting 1,000
tails in 1,000 tosses of coin
is 0.
So getting 1,000
tails in 1,000 tosses.
In future videos, we'll actually
talk about how to calculate it.
It's a very, very
low probability,
but it still is possible.
It still is possible.
So the probability is not 0.
It could be a very small
positive number close to 0,
but it is not 0.
It's actually possible.
A probability of 0 means
that it is impossible.
The probability of
winning the lottery is 0.
Once again, you can
win the lottery.
It's within the realm of
possibility, so it's not 0.
It's a very small number.
It could be close to
0, but it's not 0.
So this is false.
The probability
that the sun will
rise in the west tomorrow
on earth is 0.25.
So you probably already
know, or hopefully know,
that the sun rises in the east.
And assuming that the Earth
continues to rotate in the way
that it rotates, it will
continue to rise in the east.
Now, there is some ultra,
ultra small probability
that an asteroid of the
right mass or a meteorite
of the right mass hits
earth in the exact right way
to somehow reverse
its spin to maybe make
the sun rise in the
west, but that's
a super, super, super,
duper small probability.
That probability is very, very,
very, very, very close to 0.
It's not going to be 0.25.
0.25 is a fairly
large probability.
So if this was
actually the case, then
as we live our lives,
we would be seeing days
where the sun rises on the west.
And we clearly don't see
that, so this is false.
The probability that the Obama
family's beloved dog, Bo,
will gain access to the
President's computer,
log on to dogancestors.com,
and leave the country in search
of his long-lost relatives
in Portugal is 0.01.
So this seems, if
not an impossibility,
a near impossibility,
that the dog somehow
will know how to
log onto a computer.
This is probably
an impossibility.
And then, actually, be
able to read something
on a website, type on a website,
and then read on a website?
This seems close to an
impossibility, if not
an impossibility.
And then, somehow getting a
ticket and leaving the country,
and somehow the Secret
Service lets them?
This seems pretty
close to impossible.
So this probability is
pretty darn close to 0.
If it's impossible,
it would be 0,
but it'd be much, much
closer to 0 than 0.01.
This is a small probability,
but this is not super unlikely.
If this was the case, this means
that if we had 100 realities
like we had today, 1 out
of those 100 realities,
it would be reasonable to
expect this scenario to happen,
and we know it's a much, much
lower probability than that.
This probability is
very, very close to 0.
If this said 0.000 and it had
like twenty zeroes and then
a 1, I'd have to think
about a little bit more,
but I would say that this is
still false, that even 0.01,
as high as it is, is
still a low probability.
So we only got one
true statement,
and we got a bunch
of false ones.